[Musique]
l'archipel d'Hawaï recèle non seulement
des paysages époustouflants mais aussi
plusieurs espèces de plantes rares les
étudiants de Sherbrooke ont mis au point
un drone équipé d'un bras robotisé pour
atteindre les spécimens les plus
inaccessibles de ces espèces uniques au
monde
[Musique]
au beau milieu de l'océan Pacifique un
écosystème isolé de l'archipel hawaïen
ou abondent une végétation luxuriante
ces valises et montagnes abritent des
plantes si rares que certaines sont
vouées à disparaître
mais voilà que des docteurs en génie
mécanique de l'Université de Sherbrooke
se sont rendus jusqu'au sommet des
montagnes hawaïennes pour leur porter
secours
c'est une chance unique qu'on a eu de
pouvoir participer à ça
Guillaume Charron et Hugues Lavigne sont
co-fondateurs d'une entreprise qui
produit des bras articulés que l'on fixe
à des drones ils ont conçu un bras
mécanisé muni d'une plateforme
d'échantillonnage capable de s'aventurer
le long des bandes abruptes du paysage
hawaïen il en nommé Mamba
déployer sur l'archipel leur technologie
n'est pas passée inaperçue
il me fait penser à un serpent long et
noir avec un bras qui bandit
le jardin botanique tropical national
d'hawayi étudie les plantes en voie
d'extinction trouver dans la nature il
voit alors préservation ces experts ont
donc demandé aux jeunes chercheurs
québécois de leur prêter main forte pour
identifier les différentes espèces que
l'on trouve dans les écosystèmes de
l'archipel
[Musique]
le spécialiste en cartographie par drone
Ben neighburg et l'un des experts du
jardin botanique d'Hawaï qui accompagné
l'équipe de Sherbrooke sur le terrain
on est en train d'apprendre comment ces
plantes interagissent entre elles dans
cette écosystème interrelié
il se peut qu'on ne puisse pas
totalement comprendre comment elle
dépendent les unes des autres
se trouvent seulement à kawaii alors peu
d'experts
[Musique]
mais comment préserver ses plantes rares
que l'on trouve nulle part ailleurs
et surtout comment y accéder pour mieux
les étudier sur les falaises
complètement verticales il y a certaines
populations de plantes qui sont capables
de survivre dans ces endroits là
justement à cause du fait que les
envahisseurs peuvent pas se rendre
si les chefs de montagne peuvent pas se
rendre on s'entend que l'humain aussi
est de la difficulté à se rendre à ces
endroits là donc c'est un défi pour les
chefs et pour l'humain
avant l'arrivée du Mamba en solaïen
s'est suspendu un hélicoptère en
escaladant une falaise que les
botanistes atteignaient leurs cibles des
options limitées
peu efficace et dangereuse
descendre en rappel nous permettait
d'accéder à seulement quelques centaines
de pieds et nous limitait donc au
plantes se trouvant à la cime de la
falaise avec une telle hauteur on
s'exposait à un danger
l'invention des Québécois vient changer
la donne sur le terrain aucune route ne
se rend jusqu'en haut des falaises
Guillaume Hugues et l'équipe d'hawayi
atterrissent donc en hélicoptère au
sommet d'une montagne l'avantage
d'utiliser des drones c'est de pouvoir
avoir accès à distance aux falaises
avoisinantes donc dans une même journée
on peut rester un point puis atteindre
plusieurs falaises qui sont autour de
nous
[Musique]
on a deux composants principaux donc on
a le drone et la Mamba qui est ici dans
le fond à l'opération va démarrer le
drone va prendre son envol il va
appliquer une certaine tension dans la
corde pour revenir lever le membre
finalement
ce qu'il faut comprendre quand on est
là-bas sur le terrain on tient nos
manettes et on regarde des écrans ça
ressemble un peu à un jeu vidéo si je
peux dire le drone mènera ensuite le
bras proche de sa proie une plante rare
nichée à flamme montagne une fois
stabilisé à distance sécuritaire c'est
au tour de la plateforme
d'échantillonnage de jouer une idélice
le mamba s'approche doucement de la
cible la même mécanique équipée d'une
cire rotative s'ajuste à la taille de la
plante même au plus délicate
et à certaines plantes qui on va juste
prendre un échantillon c'est à dire le
bout de la plante où est-ce qu'il y a
les fleurs ou est-ce que les graines en
amont les scientifiques vont nous
valider quelle partie prendre puis ça ça
va faire en sorte que la plante elle va
pouvoir repousser directement sur la
falaise
une fois la plante récoltée la partie
n'est pas gagnée il faut la ramener à
bon port en sécurité
mais le temps n'est pas toujours climat
et des défis pointe à l'horizon 20 et
pluie des ennemis redoutables
on a eu un volet quand même dans des
conditions assez difficiles des fois là
on a même eu des vaches qui a 40-50 km/h
dans le centre de Lille il y a un
endroit qui s'appelle le Blue o qui est
une des endroits où ce qui est le plus
de précipitations d'eau dans le monde
quand il y a des nuages qui passent
au-dessus du bluewall la pluie commence
toutes les parois qui sont pleines de
plantes se transforme en chute donc ça
devient comme magique dans ce cas-là
notre système est quand même assez
résistant à l'eau pour être capable de
le ranger puis de rapatrier drones avec
le avec l'outil il est pas complètement
à l'épreuve de l'eau
grâce au Mamba une espèce que l'on
croyait disparue a été redécouverte
il y a une journée où est-ce qu'on a
ramené un échantillon puis en arrivant
au sol le tout de suite les botanistes
avec qui on était ont pris l'échantillon
puissent regarder comme un peu
euphorique
en fait il savait même pas qu'elle
existait sur cette île là donc c'était
une découverte en soi
il s'agit de l'isodendrillon pirifolium
aucun des botanistes avec qui on
travaillait ne l'avait déjà vu
une découverte excitante
[Musique]
plus incroyable encore le mamba a mis
lapin sur une espèce non décrite à ce
jour on est retourné à environ même
endroit où est-ce qu'on avait fait de la
première découverte on a ramené une
plante une fois atterri Adam le
spécialiste de l'état de Hawaï un prix
la plante puis regarder la fleur puis
nous orienté j'ai jamais vu cette fleur
là avant dans ma vie
[Musique]
elle était un mystère jusqu'à ce que
l'équipe récupère la plante
que c'est une espèce non décrite de
Chilia
ramener ce qui pourrait être une
nouvelle espèce au jardin botanique
c'est comme découvrir un livre mais
vivant elle recèle une histoire souvent
méconnue des botanistes
décoder ses secrets permettrait de la
préserver
en étant sur place les Québécois ont pu
enseigner leur partenaire américain à
manipuler l'engin mais le cours
technique pourrait tout aussi bien se
donner à distance on veut couvrir des
territoires vraiment éloignés on peut
pas passer que on va toujours être
là-bas puis qu'on va pouvoir offrir un
service si on peut dire donc l'idée de
rendre la technologie à ces cinq
d'utilisation pour qu'un biologiste un
botaniste de terrain que celui utilisé
lui-même je pense essentiel dans le
projet
[Musique]
pour les étudiants de Sherbrooke la
réussite est totale leurs travaux en
collaboration avec l'équipe d'hawaïe ont
été publiés dans la revue Nature
[Musique]
et qui sait le oiseau de métal et
peut-être à la plante rare ce que
l'abeille est à la fleur essentiel à sa
survie
[Musique]